hi guys hey hey
hi first of all congratulations on
season two
oh thank you um nell
any additional pressure heading into
production this time around you know
since the first season
was well received by audiences and
critics
yeah definitely i mean um i think we
just all wanted to
keep up keep the standard as high as we
can and
you know keep giving you keep keep
people interested and keep you hooked in
the show but without losing kind of the
uh the quality of the writing and
you know so i think it was definitely
there was a little bit more added
pressure
um in that retrospect hopefully we
deliver
oh you deliver kids thank you
um rupert you recently introduced your
daughter wednesday to the world on
instagram
um has it become more difficult to work
on a series like this now that you're a
father
yeah yeah kind of yeah um
it's probably the worst show to be a
part of being a new dad
not a good advert for fatherhood but
it's
yeah it's a whole new perspective but i
think it's kind of helpful as well
it's kind of it kind of makes you
understand the stakes more like
you would like or do anything
so it's it's it kind of helps you
understand dorothy a lot more
and kind of the kind of lengths you
would go
for for your kid so it's it's yeah it's
interesting for sure um now we're
learning
much more about leanne this season um
what was it like just
diving into this dark complex character
um i think for me season two
leanne is she's unfolding and she's uh
there are so many more layers to her
that we see um especially towards the
end of the season we kind of
start to see the fighter in her and the
feistier side and
the side of her that's sort of trying to
discover who she is as a young woman
and what type of person she wants to be
without maybe
being told who she is or what she is um
so i think that it's it's been a lot of
fun to be able to
kind of step into that version of leanne
and maybe shed some of her
old clothes in a way
um rupert what's in store for julian
this season
like how does his relationship with
dorothy shift i know there's a
disappearance so what can you tell us
about it
um yeah i suppose his contact has
changed a lot in this season it's a lot
about kind of managing
dorothy and not letting everything kind
of snowball and
kind of keeping the police away there's
a lot of kind of
elements but also he's kind of forced to
kind of face his own grief
and his own kind of relationship with
religion
and what does he really believe and
i think yeah he's got a lot of demons i
think in this season and he's
kind of trying to kind of stay sane and
uh he doesn't do that very effectively
most of the time so it's yeah he's he's
a he's a real
dark kind of cocktail of of kind of
different emotions so it's
yeah there's there's kind of a lot going
on famously this season